guys am i missing something when i look
at the replay of this no because when i
look at it and i'm like
really that's that's going to cause
that's going to cause a knee injury
that's going to make you miss a game
you guys are the players tell me well
not only that is it this is nothing mcl
lcl kneecap
like what
yeah that's just that's just unfortunate
but yeah hyperextension a little bit i
thought actually the extension if you
show the play right before he grabbed it
probably would have outstretched it to
more than the actual
grab up like because you're reaching so
you think something happened before it
looks like he he kind of shook it kind
of went out and then and then the pool
just grabbed that but if you look at it
he kind of
right right here
to me that would cause more
than what poole did with that that
motion right there
that's not i mean that's nothing that's
okay that's enough come on
stop it we're just getting out of hand
right now that's a that's a physical
come on man
come on that that could do nothing that
could do nothing to him that's a
structurally
strong knee that would do absolutely
nothing all right you want to try it
he just reached out
come on kid i don't have structure come
on
can it go ahead
do it again do it one more time no
that's good
if you do it one more time he's going to
show tomorrow
hey good from that angle those cameras
that's going to run
right
all right let's go let's go let's go
oh
that's sorry we're good we're good i
don't know what any of that was but uh
keep in mind what jared greenberg said
at the end of that
grizzlies when jaw didn't play this year
were 20 and five yes
edward scissorhand yeah there you go
oh chuck d we take for granted the
flawless greatness
of uh the nba on tnt and the crew the
best of them all hate
hey chuck d you're the man chuck d you
know i love you thanks for the album i
bought me a brand new record player a
record player a record player why'd you
buy brandon ricketts because i didn't
have one he sent me a vinyl yeah oh he
sent you the vinyl yeah that's deep oh
yeah oh i've been blowing up hey
chuckling he's the vinyl tutor i had a
record
have you figured out how to plug it in
yet uh rope